yeah absolutely so it was a little bit
funny because
after of course the trump rally about a
month later the pandemic really hit and
not too long after that we had um jordan
the george floyd incident in minneapolis
and after that
critical race theory really started
taking over my
entire industry i had just been doing
trainings with organizations about how
to be better managers and how to
communicate with each other and
interpersonal communication and all that
good stuff
well critical race theory came in and
took over absolutely
every single thing and the results that
i've seen have just really
they've emphasized why critical race
theory is not a good direction to go and
it's harming individuals it's harming
team cohesion it's harming
organizational productivity and yet
organizations all over the country
are spending thousands tens of thousands
some of them
millions of dollars on this training
that has absolutely no foundational
evidence to support its effectiveness
it's locals week here on the reuben
report and i'm doing a series of mini
interviews with creators on why they
decided to become less reliant on big
tech
and instead own their content community
and livelihood
with locals.com joining me today is an
organizational therapist and
knitter turned fearless political
fighter
carlin borisenko welcome back to the
reuben report
thanks for having me i am glad to have
you back on
because although we're going to talk
obviously a bit about locals and
and why you're on there you really have
become sort of a
fearless political fighter and a year
ago you weren't
in this game at all you were
a simple private person a knitter and
now look at you
you know life is funny dave you never
quite know what it's going to throw at
you but um it's been a wild ride and i'm
enjoying it yeah
so for people that don't know you we'll
we'll link to the full interview that we
did below and in effect you went to a
trump rally thinking you were
you know going to be at a white
supremacist rally and it turned out that
you were surrounded by a lot of nice
people and now you've become a big part
of the walk away
campaign and the rest of it um how are
you feeling
about the world at the moment
you know i mean it is touch and go isn't
it there are some days i'm like we are
all
incredibly tuned and there are some days
that the
yeah i just have so much faith and
confidence in the direction that we're
going in you know i've been traveling
around the country for the past couple
months doing walkaway rallies all over
the place and i've gotten to meet so
many
amazing people i've got to meet a lot of
conservatives a lot of republicans but
also a lot of people
just like us who have walked away from
the left and you know their their energy
and it's just it's a different vibe when
you're in the walk-away community
everyone is happy it's like a burden has
been lifted off your shoulders and i
love it
what's interesting to me is that you're
not just
like the average person walking away but
but in many ways your
job as an organizational therapist is is
sort of tied to why you're walking away
can you explain that a little bit
yeah absolutely so it was a little bit
funny because after of course the trump
rally about a month later the pandemic
really hit
and not too long after that we had
jordan the george floyd incident in
minneapolis and after that critical race
theory
really started taking over my entire
industry i had just been doing trainings
with organizations about how to be
better managers and how to communicate
with each other and interpersonal
communication and all that good stuff
well critical race theory came in and
took over absolutely
every single thing and the results that
i've seen have just really
they've emphasized why critical race
theory is not a good direction to go and
it's harming individuals it's harming
team cohesion
it's harming organizational productivity
and yet organizations all over the
country
are spending thousands tens of thousands
some of them
millions of dollars on this training
that has absolutely no foundational
evidence to support its effectiveness
and so
that's really where i've been focusing
on in the past couple months
is fighting back against this monster
that has taken over and
really is doing a lot of harm to
individuals and organizations and you've
done a really great job of sort of
mapping how you can stand up to the mob
and still survive because you talk about
it you've lost jobs
because of this but at the same time
you've got i'm guessing
thousands of people reaching out to you
telling you oh
this stuff this critical race theory
stuff it's leaking into my
organization how do i fight it and
everything else
yeah that's absolutely true i've
definitely been cancelled by clients but
i've also gotten clients in return and
you know really where i'm at right now
is i just want to help people understand
why this philosophy is so dangerous
because it's one of those things that
you know one of the reasons it is so
dangerous is because people don't
understand it organizations that are
implementing it do not understand
exactly what it means and so if we can
help debunk what's going on and really
help people
approach it in a more um in a more
simple way where you can just get to the
core
issue of why this stuff is dangerous
then you can help them to understand and
then fight back in their own lives
yeah so you fighting back on this and
you know having jobs canceled
and i know all too well the stories of
what happens in a personal life and uh
just
earlier today as we were tweeting like
fools
uh so the trolls were going after you
and you said you were eating your sushi
lunch and smiling so
i myself had a sushi lunch but that's
sort of a good segue to
why you're on locals because when we
started locals my
initial idea was i want to find people
who are doing good work doing something
valuable but
could still be crushed by big tech
at any moment and the stuff that you're
doing which which is true and decent and
important
the the big tech people ain't that
thrilled with those ideas
no they're not it was it funny because
right after i was on your show the first
time i started a facebook group
basically trying to have civil discourse
among people who disagreed with each
other and that group is still around and
it's still going
but almost immediately upon starting
that group it became very clear that
facebook was going to censor it and they
would just randomly delete things that
frankly had no there was no problem with
it if someone was just asking a question
that facebook deemed out of bounds they
would just delete it out of nowhere and
then i'd get a notification and so i was
really freaking out that one day i was
just gonna wake up and this group was
going to be gone and so you kind of
reached out to me and said well bring it
on to locals
and you don't have to worry about that
anymore and so that's exactly what i'm
trying to do
congratulations it's your community you
can regulate it or not regulate it it
has nothing to do with me it actually
doesn't really have anything to do with
the locals people we're just giving you
the tools to do that so what what are
you doing
on locals that you can't do as easily
when when you're on facebook or
twitter or elsewhere well you know i
mean
what's great about locals is it's like
the adult community i mean we were
talking about how we were dealing with
all these trolls on twitter today
twitter is not the adult community you
don't go on twitter to have a dog
twitter
exactly and it can be fun and all that
stuff but if you want to have adult
conversations you need
an avenue to do that and even facebook
that's it gets really hard to do it on
there
but what i love about locals is that
people are self-selecting into this
community there's that little barrier of
having to pay like five bucks a month
to join the platform so that you you
tend to get people that are much more
interested in
actually having those adult
conversations and it's just so nice
it's so calm and no one has to worry
about being canceled you don't have to
worry about being banned at a moment's
notice because
someone at twitter or facebook doesn't
like what you're saying it's just it's
it's a relief is the best way i can
think to describe
have you had any crazy people in there i
mean has anyone decided i'm gonna pay
her money so that i can be mean nobody
does it right
well i'm sure you just gave them the
idea to do that so thanks a lot
i made you a couple bucks and then you
have to decide if you want to keep them
because it's up to you
exactly but to your point no that
absolutely hasn't happened yet and you
know in my
locals community we actually do weekly
zoom calls with all of my local
supporters we actually get on just like
this and we chat with each other and
someone even said last week they were
afraid they're like i don't know if i'm
gonna vote for trump and i'm afraid i'm
gonna get kicked out of the group i was
like
no you're not going to get kicked out of
the group just come in be a reasonable
human being that's really all we ask for
it's interesting how just a couple a
couple bucks will
kind of keep the the you know riffraff
out you know yeah yeah and it just makes
it nicer for everyone it's not only
nicer for
me as the person running the community
it's nicer for everyone else there
and it allows people a way to develop
those genuine human relationships and
it's just been really really fantastic
yeah so
when you're fighting the mob i think i
asked you a version of this question
about a year ago when we first sat down
or maybe it wasn't even that long ago
time is very strange these days since
covent it's like
did that happen yesterday or four years
ago i'm not sure um
but but what is it about you do you
think that
that lets you be brave in these very
strange times because
i think the reason you've made a mark
suddenly is people are like oh
that girl's saying what she thinks and
and so many people
are afraid to do it some guy wrote a
book about that
he did he did and we're actually reading
that book in my community right now
um but you know i think what what for me
is
i mean frankly what is lacking among so
many of the people that we see out
protesting that all want these safe
spaces
is i've had to overcome a lot of
challenges in my life from
my family to different you know bullies
i've met in my life and
i think that when you overcome
challenges like that it sets you up to
take on things that are just simply
you know they're that are much more
important so i think that i've developed
the resiliency from having
you know to overcome things throughout
my life that i don't mind standing up on
a stage and saying you know this is what
i think this is why i walked away from
the democratic party and
some people are going to like it and
some people are going to hate it and
that's just the way it is but i also
think that there's
there's something to being in this every
day isn't there is that
when you when you have the hate come at
you it's a pattern and you can see that
no matter what you say no matter what
you do the hate comes in
exactly the same way is incredibly
predictable and so after a while you
start to realize that has
nothing to do with you at all it has to
do with them and where they're at and
the goals that they have and trying to
achieve those goals by any means
necessary so
i can't take it personally it's not
about me it's about that yeah it's funny
i had a tweet that was catching fire
today and i had a
very very minor typo in it and i had
like
hundreds of these trolls you know did
you have a stroke are you [ __ ] like
stuff that's much worse than that it's
like i don't really care about that
but it's like wait a minute i thought
you guys were the tolerant good people
um but maybe not as tolerant and good
as you say you are something like that
um
where do you sense uh your your
community going what what's the goal and
and how do you stay out of the the echo
chamber i mean one of the things that
i'm trying to figure out with my own
community
is that you know people are paying a
couple bucks to get in so you're
self-selecting a certain amount of
people and
and i know for people like us we don't
want it to be just like-minded people
and i love seeing people interact with
each other and
agree to disagree but how do you how do
you guard against that
you know i really want to have more
constructive discussion and constructive
debate
in my community one of the things that i
found is that it is incredibly hard to
get people
who are not trump supporters or people
on the right to join the community we do
have lefties in there and i'm grateful
that they're in there and i'm grateful
for their contribution but
i really want to see more of them so one
of the things i want to do when i have a
little down time after the election is i
want to start
doing more constructive discussions i
want to start a debate club i actually
want to have a debate club where people
get assigned their positions so they
don't get to choose them so sometimes
they might have to argue positions they
don't agree with
just to understand the other side and i
think it's very important for people to
demonstrate that they are capable of
having adult conversations and walking
away and being like it's okay to
disagree it's okay we're all gonna
survive
it's weird to be one of the adults in
the room when when there aren't
many adults in the room isn't it well
i'll tell you if you looked at my
twitter you would not think i was one of
the adults in the room but i do really
try to be in real life
well i don't know what i don't know what
it says about the estate of adulthood
like i'm making as many star wars and gi
joe references
and yet somehow i'm an adult in the room
that that's not because of me that's
mostly because of these people well i
mean that's a reflection of where the
people were fighting at are
aren't they because if we're the adults
in the room i mean they're they're like
they're the kindergarteners in the room
aren't they
all right so one more question for you
and then i want you to pimp out your
community as hardcore as you can
um what do you see as the path
to getting out of the mess that we all
feel like we're in the political mess
the cultural mess the societal
mess do you see a path out of it
that really depends on us doesn't it
because we all have to make the choice
about how we show up
every single day and if people don't
want to show
up in an adult way then they're not
going to if people
don't want to have conversations with
people they disagree with they're not
going to and i think my greatest fear
in this whole thing is that it seems as
though there are so many people that are
just addicted to anger
and outrage and fighting and that is a
physical addiction that is an addiction
just like cigarettes or drugs or alcohol
and so in order to get past that
addiction they have to want
to overcome it and i worry that there
aren't enough people that want to
overcome it but again
i'm on the ground every single week at
walkaway rallies and i see that there
are so many people that are being
kind and like truly kind not left is
kind of kind but
truly kind and empathetic and
understanding to each other that it
really does give me hope that it's
possible but
we're gonna have to see after the
election i don't think we're gonna get
there before november but maybe
afterwards
well i'm with you of course and you know
i guess i was sort of like the original
why i left the left guy but then when i
see
people like you out there i'm like oh
it's just like
it's real like it's real and it's
happening with other people
and it's great so carlin pimp it out
pimp out your locals why should people
join
yeah they should join because it's just
a group of irregular people that we get
together we chat about topics that are
on our mind every single week we do it
in the community we do it on zoom we
read books together it's super fun
people can join at kb.locals.com that's
kb.locals.com
and i will see you out there in the
field
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell